previously on scrap mechanic wait
unauthorized farming detected I can't
believe you thought you could farm on
this very inhabited planet Oh God no
robots robots angey the robots are angry
that's right we just have to survive how
do we defend it when the crops are ready
to be harvested we almost have like a
vehicle here can we just focus on what
matters more quite is r9i now is turned
to five
don't worry mark we're really getting
we're really getting this sorted out I
think I really scared though I mean
[Music]
[Laughter]
we're just gonna wrap this around and
then put in Reverse there we go there we
go that's the directions
don't worry mark we're gonna help just
here mark look look at look at how good
my car is marched look we made it
[Laughter]
you know what I'm just gonna bring this
bad boy back to the ship for mark to
hear God when I saw you coming down the
horizon I knew my life was saved
we got there you know we got there man
we got all the way there it's fine I am
way to have you guys to call my friend
I'm lucky you called it I didn't trust
you but you called it yeah I understand
what I did now just be clear is one of
those problems you couldn't have known
before actually means that's the thing
this is what engineering is about yeah
absolutely I was pouring out tears I was
laughing so good good good you enjoyed
my creation so thoroughly - me too me
too yeah yeah as well I was fashioned
all of those robots away from my plants
I was like I bet this is gonna be great
it's gonna be so good when I see this
it's gonna be worth it am i right it did
it made it here's day and you
made it you dudes wait are you ready for
number two they don't like this farming
thing they don't like it at all like a
nun yes yes mark we are coming in hotter
than ever
boy Oh speed ha ha look at us hang on
I'm refining it I hope he don't miss it
when you come flying in that's great
thank you thank you it's good to hear
you acknowledge it how do you know the
human body could sustain such speeds you
actually ran me over
listen I don't need to rub it in your
face but I think we can all see what
I've accomplished here I make a couple
of adjustments just so it's a little bit
more stable it's I know I know anybody
want the three beats I managed to
salvage my creation here's what I got
four carats Oh Bob I like what you're
doing here right right now it's like a
now it's like a hot rod now we go let's
go sidecar any of this
yeah a hole it's starting it's all right
why isn't it starting the engines are
out of gas you got gas in there oh it's
it's out its out of guess what have you
put two engines on this bad boy I kind
of want to do that I shouldn't miss it
all right to illustrate how clunky these
tires are they're just oh yeah now that
we're on yeah
oh yeah boom welcome home have you ever
been such speed we like don't act like
you're not impressed come on put out
dude why are you have you that all
you've been doing try to put out a fire
with the farming you gonna help Bob get
supplies well of course I was the fire
was in his way
Oh was it bob is that what that what um
you know what I'll give this sure yeah
buddy this is for some bit of grief this
was it the g-forces is that you heard my
viewer my sweet whip and you were just
like not a powerful enough person
[Laughter]
sometimes you're really funny man all
right cool all right but no more
laughing is a serious matter
yeah the crops almost done yeah when do
you need us to drive over there give me
like 10 seconds hey you guys I take back
my compliment you [ __ ] [ __ ] um
wouldn't it up I don't know if a fence
is gonna help at all but like the
problem is my knee-high fence didn't
exactly you know they hopped right over
that bad boy in two seconds so I forgot
I built a grave for myself
baby how are you crafting all the farm
stuff I don't I'm curious oh no no
honestly it's all just like plop it on
the ground and water it like there's
nothing you need to build I just built
the fence like by placing it I don't
know do anything interesting
yeah don't think I'm actually talented
here definitely not all right second
engine is being crafted kids twice the
speed I don't know if anyone's gonna be
able to live with that can I connect
both of them to both wheels or should I
connect one of them to each wheel that's
my front front driving real wheel wheel
it's it's tough time out here it's tough
time on the farm no more fires
ground-level boys Wow not to brag but to
do was me good good job good job buddy
good job buddy thank you thank you all
right we got a four-wheel drive vehicle
now my friends I mean oh hell yeah
yeah yeah I thought so yeah hangin I'm
coming back I want to see this we can
put a storage container on here and it's
like it's like a traverse pick up the
slightest bump Wade's chairs go fire
perfect hang on one of the wheels this
be in a real a-hole oh yeah I can see
that we're fine oh they're turning into
each other never seen more jank wheels
in my life look at the speed Lewton
monster this is nice anyway it's all
good where are we taking this bad boy
this is definitely faster than running
yeah this is definitely a better way
taking out both of my fences I didn't
want those you want to see how I feel
okay you kept your fence nine destroyed
hang on just give me a sec all right
it's fine it's fine it's fine it's fine
yeah yeah of course it's fine yeah yeah
you got it I promise I think everyone
will agree is unmatched yes absolutely
it's Cruz look at this rock fires on
this path anymore they're in the full
potential of this game I can tell you I
could have been building up a fence to
my farm you know so we don't starve but
[Music]
you know what this might not been the
best path hang on I'm gonna drive this
is not the vehicle these moves
Oh my camera died I gotta go get a new
camera battery I'll be it's okay we're
gonna be there no time by the time you
get back we'll definitely be at the
place we're going and we are here
perfect oh I'm dying I don't I'm so busy
being a genius engineer that I forgot I
have to eat and drink things wait can I
put these on here oh I totally can that
doesn't do anything but I can they're
like my they're like my fenders you know
oh yeah we're gonna put some headlights
on those puppies I have one headlight is
that good oh yeah yeah yeah
one dead center headlight oh yeah I'm
back look at the look at the front yeah
Oh counterweight there we go no no look
at the very front look at the tip if you
will oh god you guys
anything to help my crops he's gonna
build a better fence just so you know
they can't get to the fence if you look
at it okay what am i yeah I saw the
counterweights is good that's great man
that's just what you were thinking yeah
I was thinking like something like that
all right well I don't have a lot of
wood no I just need enough for them not
to be able to jump over it right away
Oh like a gate mind are we just gonna
wall it all up the nasty backups we
might as well wallet in completely right
I mean yeah actually that makes sense
wait do you know you can place more than
one down at a time hold left like you
can like spend it out put a ceiling on
right oh well the eyes are gonna be
flying robots back your concern is them
hip-hopping they're way over
they can't hip hop that they'll never be
able to hit my bad robot market handle
vehicle yeah what if we run them over
what if Bob you're running them over
whoa are they gonna attack me if I'm in
the vehicle how could they you're so
fast upgrade who just farted oh I
could've made it like fence style oh
well yeah we could just cut out you want
to just do one wide or too wide what's
your idle figured out my vision I'm so
stressed you're all in my business it's
marking a plate I'm just want a peekaboo
window on my and you can't get through
oh you can get over it oh they're coming
don't comment all right where are they
coming from I'm in the vehicle I'm ready
looks clear
I'll get coming in hot yeah oh how you
don't mind it oh it's coming for Wow Wow
God
very sorry right
yeah take some Tomatoes you guys want
mater's oh hell yeah okay chomp on those
yeah here take some of these thank yous
well that was for Bob Wow boom step your
way right on in here suddenly unless
you're a robot then don't you do it
maybe I need a wheelie bar maybe that's
the problem I think I need a wheelie bar
oh that's smart we throw your water
thanks man
I don't like the way you said that but
okay alright so what's the what's the
logical end game step after this is the
question my stick a Philly bar my dudes
now I ain't going backwards no ways know
how oh hell yeah
you pop a wheel on that wheelie bar no I
ain't going nowhere
actually I don't have another bearing do
I damn it I do have a wheel though you
just need a wheel it doesn't even do
anything
dude need a wheel let's put a like that
now it looks like it supposed to be
there yeah well actually now that now
that I see it I kind of hate that hang
on hang on I can we can we can do better
you know mark if there's anything I've
proved it's that my engineer genius
oh no bounds yeah that's why they call
you no bounds Bob look at how that looks
I just want everyone to marvel that's
brilliant
that does look good think of braces
cross braces are for nerds
there's no physics in this universe it
is a habit of yours to make everything
one unit off-center
oh this it's not my fault why'd your
[ __ ] is you did this now you put the
stairs not centered fine you want me to
fix it I'll fix it and then you just
build one of those and then you get rid
of that now it's symmetrical how about
that fair's fair's fair
no I don't I don't like it thank you
spirit if we would have made it one
thinner instead of one thicker we could
have been mad all of them things
around the whole perimeter of the thing
be exactly to gap in the fence you see
what I mean you see you see you see the
hello now you do it like this I like my
way better I don't like you I'm out of
there we go you're not even complaining
about the fact that my top stair is only
one you're not even complaining about
the worst thing I done is made a ramp
for the robots to get into my crafts you
know when they get here you just be all
big up blurred I do plane I want to get
rid of wait a minute there now it's
closed I can't closed room I can't go in
yep can't go in good robots can't jump
we know this I'm taking the Beast Oh
give me a ride do you want a ride baby
seconds before you got to be back you
better stick around uh you know what I
kind of over farm and I don't feel like
it anymore hey this actually does handle
a bit better a little bit more weight it
doesn't quite slap itself around as much
yeah and that wheelie bar that really
helps I think we have to cuz the only
other way the thing we can do is go out
and find stuff right I guess dude let's
do it let's go
should we go the other way yeah maybe a
different direction yeah oh we're gonna
go the ship ship nose way alright props
what I said [ __ ] you to the cross
oh well that's rude you know I feel like
another engine would oh really I really
got this thing going I don't think we
could have handled that amount of engine
power hey well she's trying to casually
run down this a-hole oh what a nerd huh
little robot behind us
Oh is he chasing oh what a silly nerd
we're faster than you suck it I'm an
expert I just want to see something oh
don't do that come on now
come on not like this this is in style
as a stylish stylish oh there's some Moo
cows kill them yeah seems mean right
around of apparently yeah there's gotta
be something to get a better
sledgehammer to get a better engine to
get better wheels like there's gotta be
recipes or something we just need to
check more buildings that's all we
really have we would see some tall
buildings I guess I shouldn't have gone
down oh there's a tall building mm I
think that's the one that's by the base
yeah yeah I don't think that's wait
there's a clock tower to the left
wait there's something it's like a
yellow if you go straight left see that
looks different that's not yeah that's
when you're out there's a way up here
damn that light really blasts it I know
right so we're gonna see everything
except tonight it doesn't do [ __ ] oh
that's a rock I think we got a climate
Oh car can handle it hang on hang on
let's just give it a chance you know oh
yeah actually there is a path down there
I think to the left close I trust you
there this thing's got some pep ooh what
is this ah our to the beast out here and
run you Oh
there's bad guy in here are you trying
to a douche out Frick you wanna die
you drop the circuit board
and there's a couple arms up here if I
could get him some arms right here each
ah I can't quite make that I could
probably build something out to go get
to it oh yeah that's right I got two
more beats needs for ya oh come on yeah
the lip I can just build things you want
to eat you want to see mark yeah always
always must see what an engineer does
the solve the problem I can solve this
problem with never mind
I can solve this never mind I'm up there
was nothing up here there might be
something at the tippy top of this but I
don't know well let me go check out oh
hog this the gas situation is suboptimal
there was nothing up here as it says it
turns fine
are we moving on where's wait I don't
know we're way it is turned down the
power on the beast here yeah yeah yeah
yeah wild I passed out a few times back
there jump it right off here yep there
we go some kind of building way the hell
in the distance yeah I see that I see
that
oh oh so sister full mode is brand new
ah survival mode only came out in last
Thursday that's kind of angry at us but
[Laughter]
it's a slight incline boys get going oh
how do you like them apples
oh no new components oh no I can't turn
the engine off coz the good drivers seat
I can't I move my new wheel movie over
with us how about you move the chair
over to the it's not a driver's chair oh
okay
I think I can get the engines off now
inventory all my inventory is full can
you guys pick up the stuff
pick up the engines and the bearings
sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
sorry I got I got the wheels got the
bearings got him got him all right good
stuff want to make a flips cuz make a
Forbes all right good stuff good stuff
hey there's like a floating ferry in the
distance literally a shimmering ferry oh
it's a robot never mind I'm an idiot
it's got a long Sparky tail okay well
that was an actual travesty yeah that
didn't go so good
[Music]